foreign
not sure if this song actually reminds
me of the opening titles for Sherlock or
if I'm just having a fungus field
hallucination either way I'm now more
interested in working on my Sherlock of
us fan fiction than I am in watching
this episode
I can't figure out who Ellie is talking
to here is she talking to me no
seriously is is she talking to me am I a
clown do I amuse her sorry probably got
those references all screwed up I've
never actually watched Joker this breaks
down over time this stuff's almost water
that stuff should be 100 unusable diesel
has it best a 12-month shelf life gas in
general can break down after three to
six months Joel telling me that this old
gas coming from a car currently growing
a substantial amount of moss will work
doesn't make me believe it will work
back in the day we'd drive 10 12 hours
on one tank I'm not saying there isn't a
car that can make it 10 hours plus on
one tank but they sure weren't as
plentiful as trolls making it seem with
this story it doesn't matter how much
you push the envelope it'll still be
stationary
I'm gonna go ahead and give us into
myself because I'm most likely the only
person who actually finds that joke
amusing here just make you all nostalgic
Joel is so distracted by Hank Williams
that he takes his eyes off the road for
an anxiety-inducing seven seconds this
noticeably hairless bear is the only
issue I have with this faithful
Recreation of the magazine from the game
why are all these Pages stuck together
uh
[Music]
uh I'm just with you Joe was
more scared of this question than he is
of the infected which is fair but it's
also an outdated stereotype about
fathers being scared of the talk
littering seeing this Arby's sign makes
me realize those old where did everybody
go commercials in this universe were
accurate predictions of the near future
and for some reason that makes me sad it
also makes me want a roast beef sandwich
and some Horsey Sauce to dip my curly
fries in but also the sad thing earlier
Ellie said I want to see a tank but when
they drive past them Joel doesn't say
that's a tank what a dick all right
that's enough for today and here's this
conveniently laid out turn off because
I'm tired and I'm ready to set up camp
and cook some ravioli hiding far away
from the road is a good idea however
this long and very direct set of tire
tracks is definitely giving away your
position what am I even eating that is
20 year old Chef Boyardee ravioli the
prevailing wisdom regarding the flavor
and safety of 20 year old canned food
appears to be you probably don't want to
around and find out unless it's
absolutely necessary and if your mouth
goes numb it's probably botulism I guess
what I'm saying is that Ellie shouldn't
be assuming gender fungus in that smart
this is too remote for infected anyway
so tries to let us down easy with his
hint that no fungus zombies will be
joining us in the episode Joel was
worried about the smoke from building a
fire but not about the light from this
lamp
it smells kind of good
well that would be Frank's then speaking
ill of the rotting bill
you don't like coffee jump scaring
Ellie's morning with coffee along with
her inability to not let anything around
her go without giving in to snooping so
the sin as always is Ellie and coffee
a long story is it longer than 25 hours
it's not but it's probably gonna feel
like it so I'm coming in hot and heavy
with a request for us skip the fiance is
hope for the world why bother going on I
mean you gotta try right you haven't
seen the world so you don't know you
keep going for family this is why this
story works it's about so much more than
dealing with external apocalypse
problems we get to see the characters
navigate their internal struggles as
well reminding us that these aren't just
video game avatars but real people with
emotions and fears that they must fight
along with the fungus Among Us what if
you don't find him oh well how do you
know I'm persistent oh the superpower of
persistence that always works out in the
end it doesn't get in the way of those
other superpowers like extra human
strength laser eyes and invisibility
nope persistence trumps all this will
work out well for Joel you got it pretty
early to grab more sleep I'm not even
tired
kids screw it we've never seen Joel be
the type of person to just say screw it
so this is how we know that the writers
were at a loss for how to make something
bad happen we can jog right around this
tunnel not pictured in the scene jogging
having sat through an underworld match
Stickman double feature I can tell you
with the utmost certainty that this is a
sin not the Matchstick Men portion but
the underworld portion takes all or any
of the good tastes left over from
Matchstick Men
we're left to assume this is a trap but
are these guys just always ready to pull
this clearly not that many people are
driving anymore so how often exactly
would the time it would take to set all
this up even be worth it these tires
look much more inflated right before the
crash than they did a second ago because
production put the safety of their
stunned Personnel ahead of continuity I
mean don't get me wrong that is the
correct choice but I still have to send
it
the bad guys who deal out promises say
podcast produced in association with the
same guys who send you emails about your
Amazon account being tampered with
[Music]
they're not going to hit you all those
Mandalorian episodes have allowed him to
know when he's dealing with people who
have attended the Stormtrooper School of
aiming at things
you getting pissed off that
the guy you're shooting at shoots back
at you Joel is amazingly lucky that this
guy chose to run at him when he opened
the door instead of immediately shooting
this scene has devolved into a
convenient medley of things working or
not working also our hero can survive
this seeing the reality on Ellie's face
differ from her attitude in the mirror
earlier is an incredibly powerful
character moment in a world where
children are allowed so little innocence
what little exists for Ellie keeps
getting taken from her all I can do is
remove a sin and appreciation of the
character and the performance not a
single person checks if there are any
Doritos left in this vending machine
Ellie I gotta get in there I can't fit
through Joel absolutely could fit
through the hole in the wall waiting for
three episodes and almost to the 25
minute Mark of your fourth episode to
show us Melanie lynskey you had Melanie
Linsky this whole time and you kept her
from us
a God's sake I delivered you I held you
in my hands I honestly have no clue what
Kathleen is trying to find out or why
status borons from David cronenberg's
remake of The Fly is in the situation
he's in but I'm pretty sure just being
the doctor who delivered said adult when
they were born does not give you the
right to do whatever it is you probably
did I mostly just wanted to mention the
fly but I feel strongly about the other
stuff too also it's so good to see John
Getz he's insanely underrated character
actor and I'm glad he'll be hanging
around for a long damn it this is
Henry's work
understand you surprisingly difficult to
take any threat from a person named
Henry seriously I'm genuinely shocked
she's been able to get this many people
to Rally behind her cause also show
continues to not tell us what happened
after the plane crash where the soccer
team was stranded in the woods the guy
with the beard is the first in command
because he has a beard cliche let's be
honest we all suspected the Kansas City
would be the first to go all Mad Max
nothing in this scene is the least bit
shocking you shouldn't have had to him
you know glad I did right you're just a
kid what a weird way to say thank you
for saving my life Ellie you put it in
your pack you're shooting damn ass off
fair enough but isn't there an
in-between place for her to store the
gun having her have to get into her pack
in a last minute kind of situation
doesn't seem smart this smile after
being handed a gun I know it's a
different world than our own but that
doesn't make the smile any less creepy
you yeah Barry is shockingly good at his
job and seems to know what needs to be
done but he follows all of Kathleen's
orders without question it's a very
interesting Dynamic and it's sinful that
they don't have their own show so this
could be explored further these bikes
were left to die here like this showing
us this thing which is obviously related
to the fungus only to then not talk
about it for the rest of the episode how
is this less important than some dude
named Henry kill off the building for
now saying this instead of abandoning
the city and I hate to say it moving to
Ohio
take a look around first I feel like
that would have been a good idea before
immediately jumping into the room
walking upstairs walking upstairs
walking upstairs excitement
go
what what are you doing Joel lately
Seasons the floor with glass shards
because I don't want someone sneaking up
on us while we're sleeping but he
doesn't consider barricading the door
even a little bit or not sleeping in
view of the front door where someone
could just shoot him an Ellie before
they even stepped on the glass did you
know diarrhea is hereditary what
yeah it runs in your jeans even cleverly
written poop jokes are still poop jokes
and always a sin Joe they really could
have ended on this beautiful scene with
Joel and Ellie laughing together as
their relationship has grown to the
point where there's space for humor and
joy amidst all the chaos danger and pain
and open the next episode with them
being held at gunpoint I would have been
just as impactful if the story's good
you don't need Cliffhangers
oh oh okay it's funny
it's like looking in a mirror only not
okay but just know you can't escape
while Livingston
he'll be back he will be an Unstoppable
Force for good it's actually before my
time
the winner though
[Music]
an award because he works with the
Avengers what if you don't find him oh
well how do you know I'm a hard worker I
set high goals and I've been told that
I'm persistent I don't know what to say
really three minutes to the biggest
battle of our professional lives all
comes down to today you put it in your
pack
you'll shoot your eye out kid I I look
at those cans but when we get to 20 tell
me I'm gonna throw up